you've been here for a few days now what
has experience been like thus far
honestly man it's been it's been a great
experience you know I think um
when you have when you're in one place
for as long as I was in Portland you
know 11 Seasons same environment same
people
uh you get comfortable with it and it's
pretty much all you know it's all I know
as a professional
so to be in a different environment and
to see things be done differently
um you know it's definitely been uh new
it's definitely been a transition but
the way that
my family and I were embraced when we
got here and you know to to feel wanted
and to feel desired and to feel
something fresh and new
um I feel you know I don't want to say
rejuvenated because I feel like I come
correct every year but
um you know it's definitely been a boost
in energy and and focus and you know my
excitement going into this season
especially being a part of a team you
know with
um you know a two-time MVP you know one
of the greatest players in our league
and in this game's history so
uh somebody I feel like I compliment
very well so just being in this
situation also made it that much more
exciting and uh it's different but it's
been a great couple days so far damn I
seen you when you first arrived and I
got to spend a little time with you that
Saturday when you first got here at the
end of the night you sent me a text and
you said
this is where I'm supposed to be bro
what I didn't say what change but what
what brought you to that conclusion
after all that
I mean just you know I I was able to
take in the the day and uh you know I
sat down with multiple people you know I
ran into Terry Terry stats I played for
Terry my first nine seasons
you know I ran into uh lady J Jessica
Cohen you know who was with me in
Portland the last five years uh I sat
down with Giannis and we talked and you
know running in the pack connington I
played with his first uh four years
and then you just you know you make your
way around and you start to see like the
level of the organization you know they
won the championship so you know it's a
standard you know they
you know what they desire is you know is
of that level and um
you know I've been striving for that
that's something that I've been wanting
to get closer to so to walk into that
type of environment and complement that
environment so well
for it to be a humble environment you
know small Market similar to what I've
been in so it's
it feels safe
um it feels familiar
but it's just different at the same time
if this was four years ago or five years
ago I don't know how I would have
handled it but
in this moment you know and at that time
I'm like man I'm this is what it's
supposed to be like I'm supposed to be
here
and uh you know I'm excited for what's
to come I remember a few years ago I
interviewed you and you said something
to me about a trade that I've never
thought about before you said if a
player of your caliber ever were to
request a trade yeah it affects so many
other people
like and so you you've actually seen
you've seen that with the deal right now
but and but you that was a that was a
hindrance for you before
how did you get to the point where you
were like okay I understand this might
affect other people but this is
something that I probably have to have
to do
um it
I don't think it was a
a thought out thing I didn't think it
out that way you know it was like all
right you know I'm not going look out
for other people no more you know it was
just like
how much I want the opportunity to win
um just became more powerful than me you
know worrying about other things you
know obviously I'm not going out there
you know thinking selfishly ever but it
just got to a point where I was like I
want to win
and the way that it affects me to you
know not be in a position to do what I
want you know what I want to do
the way that it affects me when I'm you
know in the off-season training you know
when I watch other people win the way
that it affected me I just was like I
have to at least have the opportunity to
do it you know what I'm saying and it
it just reached that point when you look
back at how everything unfolded are
there any I don't know regrets is there
any regrets or things you would have
second guessed over I don't know last
couple years this summer whatever is
there anything you wish you handled
differently
um no I mean I wouldn't handle anything
differently I think um even today you
know I love Portland I love the
Trailblazers organization you know so I
don't I don't regret any of my time
um in the past couple years you know I I
love going to work every day you know
everybody that I work with I love going
to work with them I love being there
um so I I wouldn't do anything
differently I think I'm here at the time
that I'm supposed to be here so and I'm
and I'm excited for it happening at this
moment and now with the expectation
levels here in Milwaukee I want to what
is a successful season now because in
Portland success was was different
um here some may say it's Championship
or bus some may say you know we got at
least get there for you what is the
level of expectations now
I mean I even like you said in Portland
even then my expectations was never
based on what other people expected or
how they saw it I know now this is a
different situation but
um I always expect to to go try to win
and
um that's that's not changed do you feel
like
is the is there pressure do you feel
internal pressure to try to live up and
maximize that within the time frame that
you have
no I think it's I think any uh
great player would tell you that they
put internal pressure on themselves like
I go to work out in the morning and put
pressure on myself to like be sharp and
to perform and to do what I'm supposed
to do
even as a father like I put pressure on
myself to you know to be the best for
them you know what I'm saying
I put pressure on myself in a lot of
ways you know but it's like a healthy
type of pressure and I think that's what
this is but also
uh
uh I think I
I'm ultimately prepared for this time
because I've had
I've had uh success I've had failures
you know High moments low moments I've
had enough of those experiences
good and bad regular season playoffs you
know injuries a couple times I've had
enough experiences to work now
you know it shaped me to be ready for
this now you know to where I could I
could handle it like I said if this was
four or five years ago and I hadn't had
the experiences that I've had you know
to lead up to this point
I think I would have attacked it and you
know I would have done what I needed to
do but I think mentally and as far as
where my game is I think I'm
I'm prepared for it at this point